ايران تهدد بريطانيا بدفع ثمن افعالها
لجعلها ايران بلدا غير امن والسبب قناه
ايران انترناشونال في التفاصيل الشدد وزير
المخابرات الايراني اسماعيل الخطيب انه
سيعتبر اي نوع من الارتباط بهذه المؤسسه
الارهابيه دخول الى المجال الارهابي
وتهديدا للامن القومي على حسب قوله وزير
المخابرات الايراني اضاف قائلا لن ندعم
الاعمال الارهابيه في دول اخرى مثل
بريطانيا لكن لن يكون لدينا التزام بمنع
انعدام امها لذلك ستدفع المملكه المتحده
ثمن افعالها لجعل ايران بلدا غير امن وعقب
تهديد اثنين من صحفي ايران انترناشونال من
قبل الحرس الثوري الايراني ردد مساعد وزير
الخارجيه البريطانيه للشؤون الايرانيه
لتحديدات الصحفيين الايرانيين في بريطانيا
من قبل الحرس الثوري واكد ان بريطانيا
تفرج مجموعه من العقوبات ضد ايران وان هذه
العقوبات تحد من الانشطه من قبل النظام
[موسيقى]